في عنا بالبيت بسه وهي البسه ورغم كل
الظروف قررت تجيب اربع بسس صغار وبوقتها
قالوا لنا ماما وبابا انه نحن فينا نخلي
وحدي والباقي بدنا نعطيهم لاشخاص ثاني
وفعلا ما كان عندهم مشكله باي وحده منهم
او تفضيل لبستيان الثاني وكان الخيار
متروك الي ولا اخواتي
وفيني اقول من هون ظهرت المشكله يلي كثير
طبيعي انه تصير انا كنت بفضل بالصين واخي
الصغير بفضل وحده ثانيه وكل حدا فينا كان
مقتنع بخياره ومتمسك فيه جدا وصلنا لمرحله
انه اخي الصغير بمجرد انه انا بحب هاي
البسه هو ما بده اياها مطلقا
ومرق شهرين ولليوم كل يوم الصبح منفيق
منعيد نفس النقاش وما بيتغير شيء منرجع له
المساء ومكانك رايح ومن هذاك اليوم ولليوم
صارت جملتي الجدليه بتقول بيتنا هو منطقه
الصراع الاولى وخصمي هو اخي الصغير
بلشت معاناتي معها الكائن الصغير من لما
كان عمري تسع سنين واليوم عمري 17 سنه انا
كريستينا السمور يافعه سوريه من السويداء
صف حادي عشر علمي ومناظره هل حكايه يلي رح
احكيلكم اياها اليوم عمرها عقد من الزمن
بلشت من لما اجى اخي الصغير على الدنيا
وعرفت انه نحن بنولد مناظرين بالفطره
تدفعنا رغبتنا لتحقيق ذاتنا واثبات وجودنا
لانه نسبه وجهات نظرنا نطرح حجج تدعم
موقفنا لا نحصل على مطالبنا وطموحنا بس
يلي اكتشفتوا كمان انه نحن صح بنخلق
مناضلين بالفطره بس بشكل عفوي وعاطفي ومن
هون ترسخت ببالي فكره الانتساب لنادي
يعلمني هالثقافي بشكل احترافي وضمن
اساسيات واضحه بلشت مع نادي المناظره
بمدرستي ومن ثم الى تجمع دمشق
تعلمت من احتكاك مع اشخاص من ثقافات
وبيئات مختلفه كيف ممكن للانسان ان يبنى
من خلال توسع معارفه ومداركم كيف اقدر
اتقبل الشخص حتى لو مو متقبلي افكاره
مبادئه كيف ممكن للانسان يكتسب بالذكاء
العاطفي القدره على الادراك والتعامل مع
العواطف لما نطور مهاره الاستماع للاصغاء
والانصات
لما بفهم الشخص بعرف ظروفه البيئه المحيطه
يلي انعكست على هالافكار بتقبلوا بس هذا
لا يعني ابدا اني استسلم لحججه
خلال هاي التجربه توضح لي قديش سلاح مهم
وقوي انه نكون مثقفين ومطلعين شو عم بيصير
بالواقع حوالينا
فالمناظر الناجح هو المناظر الذي يدعم
حججه بالحقائق وهذه الحقائق تتطلب البحث
اي لا اقدر انشئ نقاش ما بصير احكي شي مو
مقتنع فيه او سامعته صدفه او ادعم حديثي
بمعلومات مو متاكده من صحتها ومن هون لقيت
انه المناظره طورت لدي مهاره البحث
فعلا خليني اوصف هالتجربه بالفارقه بحياتي
وكل شيء حكيته
بس اسا خلونا نبعد شوي عن المناظره
كفريقين لجنه حكام جمله جدليه واضحه
وجمهور خلينا نروح للتجربه الاكثر تميزا
لما صارت المناظره اسلوب حياه
لما نعرف انه هاي الثقافه غير محصوره
بالصالونات الادبيه والثقافيه فقط بل هي
ثقافه يمكن نقل للشارع وبتصير وسيله
للتواصل والنقاش بين الناس فهي ثقافي يمكن
عيشه بل وبتجعل التواصل اكثر فعاليه
لما بتتصادم العقول ممكن يكون هالتصادم
هادم اي مبني على النقاش العقيم بس كمان
ممكن يكون منتج اذا كان اساسه المناظره
فقد دينحنا بحاجه هاي الثقافه وخاصه
بمرحله التعافي من الازمات
هلا بدي احكي لكم عن قصه جميله جدا رغم
الطابع الماساوي الغالب عليها بس هي
علمتني وعلمتني كثير ضمن فعاليه بتم فيها
جذب الاطفال المتسربين من المدارس هذول
الاطفال يلي انجبروا ويتركوا مدارسهم
وتعليمهم واكتسبت حياه المسار الخاطئ
نتيجه الاختلاط بسوق العمل يلي ما بينتموا
له وبهالعمر
فمثلا باحد المرات بنكون مجموعين بيجي طفل
من الخارج لينضم للاجتماع وفجاه بيركض
وراه طفل ثاني وببلش العراق نحن ما بنعرف
ليش
لندرك بعدين انه قبل هاي الاجتماعات وحتى
بعدها في مشاكل وخلافات كثير
اوجدوا من العراق الوسيله الوحيده
ليدافعوا عن نفسهم وعن افكارهم
نحن ما فينا نرجعهم لمدارسهم وتعليمهم
بشكل كامل نحن بنسمعهن نفهمه نعرف اسبابهم
منحاول نساعدهم الى نظام تعليمي خاص فيهم
يعوضوا فيه الفاقد التعليمي والمعرفي
وضمن هاي الاجتماعات وهاي الجلسات كان في
طفل مميز جدا بالنسبه لالي كل الاطفال
بكفي وهو بكفي ثاني كان مميز بالتنافر
الواضح بين ملابسه وشخصيته فهو كان حنون
لطيف حكي وحلو كنت اجي لاقعد معه وادعموا
حاول ارسم ابتسامه ليجي فجاه ويسبخني وما
يكتفي بس برسم ابتسامه بل مع الوقت صار
دافع للاجتماع بهذول الاطفال
مرق اجتماع واثنين وما شفته
كل مرات بكون ماشيه بالشارع وفجاه بشوف
هالطفل الوسيم صاحب الظهر المنحني على احد
السيارات يتحامل سطل وبايد حامل اسفنجي
وواضح عليه قديش عم يشتغل بكل طاقته ليحصل
على بعض النقود نقعد انا وياه وبنعيش
المناظره انا عندي قضيتي وهو عنده قضيته
ما في لجنه حكام بس انا وهو وافكارنا
المختلفه
انا كنت عم فكر للمستقبل البعيد كيف راح
يكون وهو كان عم بفكر انا كيف بدي اجيب
نقود لاكل اليوم
استمرت مناظرتنا لحوالي الخمسه واربعين
دقيقه والانجاز العظيم كان لما وصلنا لحل
وسط يوافق فيه بين عمله يلي عم يامن له
مستقبله القريب وبين التزامه بهذه الجلسات
فعلا هالتجربه علمتني كثير بس يلي بدي
اخبركم اياه انه نحن نقاشاتنا بتختلف
باختلاف الاشخاص اللي عم يتناقشوا ثقافات
وموضوع النقاش وبالتالي رح ينعكس على
اختلاف النتائج بس الشي الوحيد المشترك
باي نقاش ما في شي اسمه فوز وخساره هي
عمليه متبادله اي لما لما يتم اثبات خطا
بافكاري لا يعني الخساره ابدا
وتمسك الخاطئ بافكاري وعدم قبولي لسماع
الاخر لا يعني الفوز ابدا هي فرصه رائعه
بتخليك تحول افكارك من جيده لرائع
هالطفل خلى افكاري
واقعيه وملامسه للناس اكثر
مثال واحد ممكن نعيشه باي يوم ومثله كثير
على كيف نخلي المناظره اسلوب حياه مين منا
لما بينزل مع امه على السوق وبفاصل للبيع
ما بفاصل البياع السعر هل حدث وعلى بساطته
هو مناظره كثير منا حاليا
خطر بباله مواقف عشم ممكن كان يعرف انه هي
المناظره وممكن ما كان بيعرف
ولكن انت مناظر وحتى ان لم تعلم بعقلك
المنفتح ثقافتك الواسعه تقبلك للاخر
وقدرتك على الاصغاء لنعيش المناظره فهي
ثقافه تستحق ان تعاش وهلا خلونا نرجع شوي
لموضوعنا الاساسي برايكم
ولا بسه اخي شكرا
[تصفيق]